welcome back to cbs mornings that is
top's friendly market in east buffalo
new york where the investigation into
the deadly mass shooting over the
weekend is still going on an 18 year old
white man is accused of what police call
an act of racially motivated violent
extremism ten people were killed and
three others were hurt
this was one of five mass shootings to
occur in this country from friday
evening to sunday night we saw them in
california texas wisconsin and north
carolina along with western new york in
chicago where gun violence has become
routine five people were killed and 35
wounded in shootings over the weekend
president biden plans to go to buffalo
tomorrow to meet with the community ed
o'keefe is at the white house ed good
morning well good morning all of those
shootings you mentioned from over the
weekend once again raise questions about
what if anything should be done to curb
the rise of violent extremism in this
country or to regulate firearms
president biden addressed a police
memorial service sunday here in
washington he called for unity he
mentioned the shooting in buffalo but he
didn't make any mention of gun control
he has taken some steps to crack down on
gun violence through executive action
and just on friday he urged mayors and
police chiefs to use some of the federal
pandemic relief money they've received
in the last two years to boost police
and public safety budgets but democrats
have been blocked from passing major gun
control legislation for years notably
over the weekend house speaker nancy
pelosi said her chamber is going to try
to take up legislation again in the
coming weeks to combat domestic
terrorism but even so whether it's
shootings at flea markets supermarkets
classrooms churches outside nba games or
inside shopping malls there is no sign
that the white house and congress are
going to take meaningful action to
address gun control or the rise of
violent extremism anytime soon gail
that is so disheartening to hear under
these circumstances thank you